sammy you're amazing
you said you're amazing they love you
it's good
[Music]
they're making fun of me no they said
you're amazing for real
look you're gonna have some people that
like you and some people that hate you
that's just life
i got a lot of people that hate me and a
lot of people that love me
oh yeah hey uh shout out to andy ditch
andy ditches in the chat tonight we'll
get to you tomorrow man
we're not don't worry well i was gonna
say i saw your video andy but i didn't
actually see your video
people that keep sending me your video
uh
and it's it's on my you know it's on my
list
i'll look at it i saw the title i you
know
andy ditch's videos are kind of like a
buzzfeed article you read the title and
you kind of get the gist of
you know i mean you don't you don't need
to listen to the [ __ ]
the the headline stretched out over
three paragraphs
we got it we pick on you we're mean um
wipe your ass and move out of your
parents house you [ __ ] filthy
degenerate
yeah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
seriously
like just stop it just stop it and get
some help
you just gotta keep moving stay positive
and trust god
for real
ew what is he doing
[Music]
all right here's what we're gonna do i
got an idea right
let me see if i can do this
let me see if we can get sammy and biggs
to collab
all right
love our military they're important and
when i'm
in the jam when i'm in the gym i know
that i can call up the man can't call up
the man with a plan
when i'm on the run when i'm on a run
[Music]
it works
[Music]
i'm telling you man we can make stars
out of these two
[Music]
fake catholic garbage human piece of
[ __ ]
by the way you know i get it i i get the
whole
[ __ ] big thing but like
as long as i've been doing this
i can never understand the people
who actually give money to the people
they hate
right like like
you calling me a fake piece of [ __ ] or
fat piece of [ __ ] loser drunk
couch whatever all that [ __ ] you could
say whatever you want
but almost anything you say about
another person
is immediately negated by the fact that
you're giving them money
um
it just doesn't you know what i mean
like it doesn't to me it doesn't make
any sense
like you understand most people would
probably let you insult them for five
bucks
most normal people i think that if you
went up to somebody and went
if i give you five dollars can i make
fun of you almost anybody would go yeah
absolutely give him the money
um so i don't understand the whole i'm
gonna keep donating over and over again
and calling you a piece of [ __ ]
um i mean it's one thing if you donate
one time and you make it worth it
maybe maybe maybe you can make it
hurtful enough
or good enough but like most of the time
it's like every 10 minutes three bucks
[ __ ] dick [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] fake piece of [ __ ] you're like
every time you do that
i'm getting a few bucks um
disco swayze on twitch says uh she
reminds me of a blonde
uh shot blackhead
uh oh she reminds me of schatzy
blackheart
uh reckless what was it what did he say
just reckless and tricky
it's very funny
uh keep playing i want to sing
can you just play the guitar and let me
sing a little
okay just keep doing that same chord
progression
could you just uh play that same chord
progression by the way it's no point
because starkiller says more likely
they've refund what they donate
um i know from wings who [ __ ] about
re of we i'm
assuming you're talking about wings of
redemption who [ __ ] about
uh donation refunds now i don't know how
it works on twitch i know he does
most of his [ __ ] on twitch but i will
tell you this starkiller
and i will tell this to anybody out
there who donates to shows and thinks
that they're going to get a refund
it is next to god damn impossible
to get a [ __ ] refund from streamlabs
super chats i don't know how it works on
youtube super chats
i don't know how it works on um i don't
know how it works on
twitch but when it comes to stream labs
when it comes to paypal
when you click that little thing and
it's like i'm tipping on stream labs
there ain't no refunds uh i've issued a
few once in a while
as a [ __ ] you to some people like as you
know as either a [ __ ] you or as
a um you know
as a way of just saying like look i want
your money but
as far as like reporting somebody and
trying to get a refund
that [ __ ] ain't happening on a stream
labs if the person on the
now if the person who
that you got the stream the super chat
from their show
if they're not good at fighting it they
might get it taken away but
i've never had a refund on paypal that i
didn't initiate
um it's it's almost impossible because
you just explained to them like
they're they're becoming very very um
they're becoming very very uh aware of
the streaming world
at these processors now and they kind of
understand
super chats and what they are and this
and that um and there is no
legal recourse for it it's your tipping
it's a tip it's a digital tip jar
you can't go to a bar and go i don't
like that bartender she wouldn't give me
her number at the end of the night i
want all my tips back
give me her tip jar i want to get my
money back out it doesn't work that way
um so yeah it's kind of hard to pull
that off i want to sing a little bit
can i yeah
so i'm chilling here with sammy and it's
been a real good night okay i'm sorry
but ron john says
they get refunds from wings of
redemption because they claim he sells
vacuum parks they made a whole business
in his name
jesus christ by the way i have been
watching the
that guy lumix this is dude lumix who
has a channel
that only does wings of redemption clips
and he's so [ __ ]
dude some of the [ __ ] cuts he puts
together our whole
the wings of redemption is a very very
depressing guy to watch like there's
something about dark side phil
that i actually like because darkseid
phil is one of these guys he's
and he's obnoxious but he just somehow
survives everything and just remains
plucky and
upbeat he does it he's just he's just
like an idiot he's
he's got a mr magoo quality about him
like dsp
just is just bumbling through life and
somehow still making it
um but wings of redemption doesn't have
the whimsy
you know what i mean like dsp is funny
to watch wings of redemption is
very sad to watch
i think she has a nice smile
i think she's quite all right
and i love the time we had together
don't care what they say i know
sammy will get better and i will be
[Music]
okay
oh
[Applause]
this is tough this one's hard man this
is
oh god this is a tough one
we got to make it through this so we
have to get through this
and i love her
and god loves her
[Music]
i pray for her every day
thank you for the day we've had together
and i'll see you once again
maybe at taco bell
sammy i love you whatever i gotta head
out here
you're not giving me a real chance no i
gotta get i gotta go
i love you give me a hug
i love you stay safe i'll be praying for
you okay you got my number
i can play guitar a lot better than that
oh my
god she thinks this is a rehearsal much
love it's gonna go
everyone say bye to sammy we love sammy
thank you sammy
do you want to see more of my house i
gotta go home it's two
it's 2 a.m
sorry look at my room
just oh
oh god oh god oh
god now i just feel so bad
oh i feel so bad you know like that's
i feel everybody's saying she wants the
day
it's it's not just that i mean she might
want to [ __ ] him whatever but i don't
it's not
no i it's literally like i i think
it's more that she's in an rv
in the desert and
her entire life is just an abstract
failure
or an abject failure rather um
and she just doesn't like that's that's
ah this is this is
oh man this is hard this is hard to
watch man
ah this is this is where it gets rough
man this is where it gets
rough but yeah it's definitely not like
a shoe
she really just doesn't want to be alone
and she's in it wow
god i feel bad for this girl now
hey hey we can we can hang out tomorrow
how about that
we can hang out tomorrow
[Music]
i am crying well how about we go to bed
and then i
we can hang out tomorrow does that sound
good yeah
all right please don't make fun of my
eyes no you're fine you're you're
you're chilling your eye's fine of
course
you're gonna be fine hey if anything
unsafe happens just give me a call
you have my number make sure you have my
number
do you want your choice um i finished it
do you have like a garbage
you obey money and fake catholic piece
of [ __ ] you will
what is wrong with that one they're
being crazy really mean
all right well um
you're gonna be fine though just give me
a call i gotta head out it's really
really late
uh i had a fun time with you though
thanks for thanks for hanging out
[Applause]
huh you're welcome you're welcome i
appreciate
oh my god dude this is that this is
levels of
that and
and what kills me
wait what kind of like actually like
bugs me what gets me kind of like
feeling bad for is like
there there is something earnest in this
girl like you know what i mean like
there's something
there's something very genuine in
uh and this girl had something happen to
her as a kid
and she went when somebody can just be
that pathetic
and i'm not even saying this in in in an
attempt to make fun of her but i mean
like legitimately like pathetic
um that's a hard place to get back from
you know what i mean and
that's that's it just kind of feels
pathetic um
that she's like please don't leave i'll
play the song better next time like
that's
ah [ __ ] man you know what i mean like
that that's part like
i can tell by the way and i can tell
when he's being [ __ ] manipulative
right
like look right i think i've been pretty
pretty brutal when it comes to women
because i'll be honest most of you are
sort of full of [ __ ]
uh all you are playing some kind of game
even when you don't realize you're
trying to play a game you all have these
machiavellian tendencies
but i feel bad for this one because like
she's not manipulating
which when she says something like i'll
play the song better next time
that's that somebody profoundly broke
this girl
um you know and it's like i just feel
like you know what i mean it's one of
those things that i would have even
gotten sucked into staying longer i
would have been like
yeah yeah sure yeah let's
yeah let's uh yeah let's eat some
rotten macaroni and cheese and i'll i'll
listen he play guitar some more i guess
you know what i mean like
you would just be like [ __ ] like i want
to leave but i feel really bad
you know that was that was legitimate in
my opinion